is there like a spectrum of how on the
take you can be are there ethical lines
that you can cross some of it is money
and then
is it possible to operate in a gray area
that does not
result in destructive ethical violations
deep ethical violations I have no idea I
don't think I don't think there is
realistically I mean anything that kind
of supports some of these groups you
know you're supporting things of a
horrible nature uh there I just posted
recently on my Instagram account of a
lady that was in Guanajuato
she's one of seven recently assassinated
women that are looking for their kids
basically
uh there's a bunch of uh groups and
organizations out there in Mexico and
some in Tijuana that I've actually
walked with
who are
taking control of trying to find the
bodies of their kids
that's her up there Maria Carmela
Vasquez a mother who searched for a
missing son was shot to death outside
her home
on Sunday her son Osmar Vasquez
disappeared on June 14th the 46 year old
woman is the fifth mother to be killed
this year while searching for their
missing loved ones she was a member of
the Pena missing person Collective
there's many groups out in Mexico who
basically have given up on trusting the
government to find their kids
um the number of missing in Mexico is uh
the vaded topic because you know the
government itself doesn't release those
numbers or at least hasn't uh done a
good job about keeping them and or
releasing them
um Mexico was a country that has
industrialized Body Disposal you know
and Tijuana we had these two maker the
legendary stew maker which is a guy that
basically
used Caustic Acid acid uh to get rid of
bodies at a massive level so there's a
separate operation for getting rid of
bodies and murdering at least at least
in Tijuana we saw that phenomenon and I
I it's it's obvious that it's it's going
on all over Mexico who's having those
discussions about
mass murder and getting rid of people
I've been reading a lot about World War
II recently and there's was aggressive
Innovation on the Nazi side of how to
get rid of large number of people
because For the Longest Time both the
Soviets and the Soviets were more brutal
with this it's literally it's a
engineering problem of how you kill a
large number of people and get rid of
their bodies so the Soviets were more
into
uh just laying people laying people down
into the grave face style and then
shooting them in the back of the head
and then doing that in that scale so you
just pile people on and then there was
obviously Innovation with the Holocaust
in terms of gassing people and all that
kind of stuff I'm not sure exactly where
these
tradecraft skills are coming from
specifically you hear discussions of
Israelis training some of the cartel
groups back in the late 90s uh
specifically the Aryan fuse cartel
there's a lot of stories about that a
security specialist coming down and
showing them things like how to make
caustic soda
um how to put rocks inside of bodies and
then chicken wire them around and to
throw them into the ocean or or Rivers
so that their bodies don't float
and when you kind of put rocks inside of
body to make sure the body doesn't float
so you uh you open up the intestinal
tract put rocks inside
uh you cut where tattoos are or you take
off hands and faces and throw them
somewhere else and you wrap them in
chicken wire so make it not identifiable
yeah and throw them into a body of water
and this is
this is a horrible thing but it's a
craft it's a tree craft it's a trait
it's it's train craft and it's uh it
there's there's a link to the EOS as far
as trade graph you have to remember that
uh the United States had a thing called
School of the Americas and and the CIA
and they showed things and a lot of that
stuff is out there in the hands of
people that are of that generation
so yeah there's a manual there's a
manual sign uh like with chapters and
it's like how to get rid of the body
there's manuals out there under time
constraints or what what are how
identifiable can the body be afterwards
what what a geographical constraints all
that kind of stuff I think I think that
was common back in the early 2000s uh
and maybe the late 90s when some of
these things were going on
but they've lost even that as far as
respect for the government or bodies
being found right now you what you
usually see is just bodies being burnt
to a crisp and buried in the field
somewhere that's usually what you'll see
uh some of the groups like this uh this
woman uh that this woman belonged to
basically taken upon themselves to go
out to find uh clandestine Graves uh in
the outskirts of of the towns that
they're that they live in
um probing the ground with uh these
metal probes
and seeing if the uh the whatever they
encounter in the bottom of these uh
these clandestine Graves stinks or not
uh if they find IDs or clothing they
kind of gather that and they basically
presented to the investigative
authorities in the towns or the states
they live in which basically are doing
their jobs
you know over 90 percent of all murders
in Mexico were never solved uh I mean
it's uh so they've they've even stopped
trying to get rid of bodies in that way
you know